we only we were getting an Apple watch
today but this razor thin new MacBook
now that's a surprise the new all-metal
MacBook is 12.1 inches and comes in at
only thirteen point one millimeters
thick that's extremely thin it's the
thinnest laptop Apple's ever made and
it's 24 percent thinner than the 11 inch
MacBook Air it's really incredible in
the hand it's only 2 pounds it has this
Retina display that's thirty percent
more energy efficient than that in
previous models and you can see just how
amazing it looks with something like
this now the logic board is much smaller
to accommodate this smaller case and all
around it are these batteries that are
terrorists instead of being flat this
lets them cram a lot more into every
crevice of the case giving you a full 9
to 10 active hours of battery life it's
a lot more than you'd get maybe even 35%
more than you get with flat rectangular
batteries now there's onboard
connectivity via Bluetooth and Wi-Fi so
you can get on the internet without
problems but there's this new connector
here that acts as the power connector
and your only access to drives and other
devices
it's called USB C and includes USB
DisplayPort power HDMI and VGA all in
one the only other port on the computer
is a headphone jack on the other side
now the new keyboard uses the butterfly
mechanisms under the keys which gives
you a much more even push you don't get
that kind of wobble you would get with a
normal keyboard the trackpad is entirely
solid-state but when you push it you
feel like you're getting a depression
but it's actually a haptic mechanism
under the trackpad that vibrates now
this MacBook won't replace the MacBook
Pro or the air it'll add to the lineup
it'll have a 1.1 gigahertz dual-core
processor 8 gigabytes of memory and 256
gigabytes of solid-state hard drive it
comes in silver Space Gray in this
beautiful gold color we have here it'll
start at $12.99 and ship April 10
[Music]